lawmakers could send President Trump an
emergency spending bill today providing
eight point three billion dollars to
fight the virus and find a vaccine then
Tracy's at the White House for s-bend
good morning eight point three billion
that's a lot more money than the Trump
administration originally asked for it
sure is the administration initially
asked for two and a half billion dollars
which is an amount even some Republican
lawmaker said underestimated what's
really needed the president now says
he's happy to take as much money as
Congress is going to give as the corona
virus spreads the president continued
his efforts to calm Pollock fears
calling in to Fox News last night it's
you know a very very small number in
this country but he challenged an
estimate from the World Health
Organization this week that 3.4 percent
of coronavirus patients worldwide have
died I think that 3.4 percent is really
false numbers now this is just my hunch
because a lot of people will have this
and it's very mild
personally I would say the number is way
under 1% this month the House Oversight
Committee launched an investigation into
the administration's response including
reports that there were flaws in some
tests and facing criticism for a slow
rollout of test kits president Trump
blamed his predecessor the Obama
administration made a decision on
testing that turned out to be very
detrimental to what we're doing the CDC
director said that under the Obama
administration certain labs were limited
in their ability to conduct tests
without FDA approval but that was
intended to increase regulations that
had not been updated in years the
government says it is now distributing
1.5 million coronavirus test kits and
the Centers for Disease Control is now
allowing anyone with symptoms and a
doctor's permission to get tested and
while the administration has fought
against government expansions of health
care the vice president announced last
night that costs of coronavirus tests
will be covered by private insurance as
well as Medicare and Medicaid but the
vice president left the briefing without
addressing the uninsured now afterwards
an aide did say that the government
would cover the cost for those without
insurance now as for the Pres
and challenging the mortality rate of
the coronavirus we should note that some
medical experts do agree with him
because they say at this point we just
don't know the full scale of the
outbreak Gayle all right Ben thank you
that is a question
you